[Music]  we need heroes we need you Captain  Marvel is about somebody who goes on a  journey of discovery and I think it was  really important for Bri to learn how to  fight by the time we started shooting I  had been training for nine months and  I'm glad that I did  doing my sequence is up and down and  trained for three days  I'll never live the thing that I found  so unique about this character was that  sense of humor mixed with total  capability and whatever challenge comes  her way  you're not out of life as thing you see  which I realized after going to the Air  Force Base is really what Air Force  pilots are like that's a yes or no  question yes  missing you ended a dogfight we were on  offense we were on the defense we got to  6.5 G's amazing it's a lot a lot of work  she brings so much of that to the role  it's pretty awesome  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]